so are there any Dimensions between 2
and 3 or between 1 and 2 well yes there
are fractional dimensions and we call
the enchanting creatures that live there
fractals now let me introduce you to a
fractal friend of mine this snowflake
has detail at every scale
one-dimensional lines are jealous of the
infinite length of these sides and
two-dimensional shapes are as skeptical
that this snowflake could have a finite
area so that's why they need us to be
their friend each line can be broken up
into four fragments each 1/3 the length
of the original line to continue making
the pattern indefinitely the dimension
of the snowflake will be where the
number of fragments multiplied by the
length of each raised to the dimension
remains constant so if we start with one
fragment of length one then get four
fragments of length a third that gives a
dimension of
1.26 somewhere between a line and a
filled in shape